we welcome in from the worldwide leader
in sports someone we haven't spoken to
in quite some time dan rolofsky back
here in the show how are you dan
i'm doing well rich it's good to be back
with you buddy great interview with matt
i can uh
i can attest i i get to enjoy some golf
trips with matt yep
um he's got a lot of nicknames that are
worthy of the
worthy of the i guess the description so
um he does a good job
okay with the with the libation and
whatev
what you were referring to is him being
on in 2019 when everybody was chugging
beers
um after rogers aaron rodgers had
problems doing it with bhaktiari on the
other side of the court
in milwaukee um and i've been trying to
get matt to take a a different nickname
than
matty ice for quite some time
unsuccessfully but matt's going to be on
tomorrow's show it still does not keep
him away from saying yes when i invite
him on this program
good that's good good did you think the
falcons made the right maneuver fourth
overall
dan olofsky in the draft a couple weeks
ago yeah i did
you know because two reasons one rich i
think matt still playing at a really
high level
i think matt ryan probably has three or
four good years of
can we win a bunch of games division
title make
playoff run football left in him i think
that answer is a resounding yes
and the second reason would be i think
they're a lot better than their record
was last year and i know we come from
the nfl world where you are what your
record is and that's fair and all that
stuff
sometimes that's not necessarily true
you know and that
four and twelve last year very easily
could have been seven and nine
candidly and and probably should have
been eight and eight and so
i think they're a football team that
went and got arthur smith
because of a lot of different reasons
but they believe he's ready to go take a
quarterback that can win now
and coach him now and then i think that
the talent on the football team
certainly offensively is better than the
record was and so
they're a team because of their schedule
and it doesn't look to be
brutally difficult this year i actually
see them as a team that could surprise a
lot of people and make some noise
obviously the addition of kyle pitts is
enormous
for an offense that was already really
good so yeah i i 100
thought that i went back and forth back
and forth through the months of march
and
you know a little bit of april it's like
what they should do but at the end of
the day
i settled into thinking that they should
100 percent take kyle pittsburgh's there
and build around matt
well i mean it might have been a
different ball of wax to be very honest
had you know uh trey lance been sitting
there had the 49ers
surprised everybody and taken uh justin
fields off the board or the initial
thought
of mack jones if that actually been the
case
you know i i just think when it comes
down to the choice of who was remaining
at quarterback for them and kyle pitts
with the the amount of money that ryan
is making right now
and the virtual impossibility of um
trading him or or
moving him that that right pitch sitting
there as generationally talented as he
appears to be that's the winner
i thought that was a smart move by them
too to be honest yeah totally
and then what do you do like let's let's
play the hypothetical game if you're the
falcons and kyle pitts is there and trey
lance is there right
and over the next two years matt ryan
continues to be your starting
quarterback but you're a
you know an eight and nine football team
so to speak right or a nine and eight
football team yes
and that doesn't get you in the seven
football team and you don't get in
and you're sitting there going well
we've got this first round draft pick we
think he's going to be really good we
don't know because he hasn't played but
he's just sitting there on the bench and
we could be an impactful player away
from being a a win or more
per season two wins or more per season
then you're in the dance and god only
knows what happens and so
that's why i think like the reality that
they're a better football team than
their record was last year
and you don't want to be sitting there
going you know what we we might have had
a chance
you know within our division and in
within the nfc playoffs to make a run
but we we chose to kind of
go to the future dan arlovsky here on
the rich eisen show what what do you
think about
justin fields and where he wound up and
i know your commentary on justin fields
throughout the
the draft process definitely uh made
your life a little bit more interesting
for a few days i think
so what do you think about the way it
all wound up dan orlowski
yeah it's not it's not the ideal fit for
a player just because chicago's reality
you know chicago's reality twofold one
that their organization with the general
manager and head coach like you need to
prove two things this year that you can
win
and that you can develop the young
quarterback neither matt nag either head
coach or ryan pacer general manager
is going to get an extended look at the
second
opportunity to develop a young
quarterback that you you know
that this doesn't happen in the nfl
right usually you get a chance at a
young quarterback at those roles
and if you fail to do it you're gone and
so
the reality that they need to go develop
him quickly
i think forces him on the field sooner
than you ideally want
perfect world want and then two you have
to win football games doing it you know
and i always say
that the challenge for a young
quarterback going into the nfl one of
the greatest challenges is
you're expected to do both for some
teams you know you're expected to
develop which means
breaking old habits learning how to
study tape
versus watch tape develop new good
habits
champions spending habits that's like
developing right
finding what you don't do well and
working at it to make sure it doesn't
become
your fatal flaw that's the development
of the quarterback oh hey also you have
to win on sundays
and as athletes often when winning above
everything is the most important thing
you revert back to old habits and so
it's hard to kind of break those things
and create new ones while doing it and
so
i don't love the the the landing spot
for justin um
i do think that he will be and should be
their day one starter
um one because their their weaknesses as
an offense is their
their offensive line it's not dominant
well his athleticism can mask some of
that
and then two you want him to be playing
his best football in november and
december and so repetition
matters for that and what's best for
justin fields is not what's best for
matt maggie
what's best for justin fields yes get
acclimated to the nfl
get yourself ready um you know wait a
couple weeks till it's your turn so to
speak well matt maggie again needs to
win
and show well early on and so i think go
play i think go play early on
um but there's ways to get him to be
successful on the field absolutely
it's interesting you say that about um
it is a rarity
for for a coach and a general manager to
get
another opportunity at uh coaching up
a player at this position who's drafted
in the first round certainly more rare
for the general manager to be kept
around to be able to trade up
again for another quarterback at least
for nagi
he was a coach of the year in his first
year with trubisky and then we all know
less than and they did make the playoffs
last year but put it all together with
what you just said
you know nagy came on the show i guess
it was like 10 days ago
and you you i'm sure you heard this as
well from from
from from him uh his plan is to sit
fields as long as he possibly can like
he he he wants to
make him the mahomes to dalton's
um alex smith and i even had to say in
the middle of the conversation
i don't think you're going to get that
luxury
and you're sitting here saying he's got
to pop him out there week one like
let's go deep into the pool and figure
it out from the start
like i i think i think you're more
closer to reality than
than what yeah the coach is attempting
and rich i think two things
really you know like listen justin
fields
physically is very much so ready to go
play in the nfl he's not gonna be
perfect he's gonna make mistakes there's
i pointed out all draft season there's
two issues with this game that he's
gonna have to get better physically at
but talent wise he's ready to go and i
think for
matt nagy it's not necessarily first of
all
being ready to play in the nfl as a
rookie quarterback is like being ready
to be a parent
you don't really know until you're out
there like yes
you know like who's actually ready to
have a child i don't know you just
figure it out when it happens
and so it's the same with being a
quarterback man like you go out there
and i think
for matt nagy the big thing to figure
out is where's justin
mentally with you got to have a force
field around you
when it comes to because you're going to
struggle and so is he mentally ready to
handle like the scrutiny
and the hate and the expectations and
the boobs
you know and he's is he mentally ready
to have some success as a rookie as well
not like yes you got to go in the huddle
and call the plays and intellectually be
able to understand that but justin can
do that and so
i think that matt and aggie don't hold
them back you know and
everyone continues to say the mahomes
thing
yeah first of all it was a playoff
caliber roster
both defensively and offensively in
kansas city
he had one of the greatest offensive
minds in the history of the game
and andy reid and alex was a absolute
stud
i don't think that replication of that
is in chicago
by the way great analogy dan i got
benched many times in that 2008 season
when my firstborn came home
uh it wasn't pretty no i fought through
it i ran outside
many times
well done dan orlowski here on the rich
eisen show
uh what do you make of ryan kerrigan's
signing
in philadelphia from washington football
teamer to philadelphia eagle
and how you see the nfc east playing out
and the thing i
find so fascinating about the nfc is
very rare does a scheduled release
actually intensify a conversation about
a division
it seems washington football team in
particular
finishes all five games of their regular
season schedule
in division it is something else that
division is going to be totally up for
grabs entering december i'll give you
the floor on the kerrigan signing
and uh what you think about this
division
yeah the kerrigan signing is a good
solid signing by philly
um i think he's i don't think we're
expecting ryan kerrigan from the last
you know five years ago in washington
josh sweat
is probably gonna be their main guy in
philadelphia as far as a pass rusher but
you know kerrigan's certainly going to
be able to come in and be a situational
pass rusher
um and just add another body to their
defensive line philly's actually done a
quietly solid job of kind of putting
together a decent roster because three
months ago it was a bad football team
talent-wise
so i think it's like a good solid
signing i'm not going to make a huge big
deal about it
the nfc east is going to be really
fascinating to me because
you know there's so many if attached or
there's a giant
if attached to each team when it comes
to okay
who am i going to peg to win it like i
if if you told me ryan fitzpatrick
is going to look like 50 of last year
give me washington i think they got a
chance to have like a top three defense
and the whole nfl give me washington
um if daniel jones takes a relatively
big step in year three and saquon comes
back and looks like saquon
well i like the giants then you know
really good because their defense is
going to be
really really impressive if dallas's
defense is
an absolute embarrassment in a debacle
well dallas is intriguing then
but dallas's defensive line gave up
three and a half yards per carry
before touching the ball carrier left
so like you gotta that's gotta take like
it that
we need to see a josh allen type of jump
from that defense
um if jalen hurts becomes a player that
like is is even exceeding expectations
then i'll take philly
so that's why like i sit here today and
i go all right if i was a betting person
give me the washington football team i
think they're the best football team i
think they're the best coached football
team
and that division second candidly i'm
taking the giants i think the giants are
going to be a lot better than people
expect and i love their defensive
coordinator
then i'll take dallas and then i'll take
philly i know this is the lowest of
low-hanging fruit and i love jason
garrett that is my way of saying with
all due respect
so many people are like garrett with
daniel jones they're like this is a big
year for daniel jones i mean the the
owner john mara's already come out and
say we think
this is a playoff type caliber player
that this is the moment
like when eli started taking off and
that this is the guy that now has
kenny gallaudet to go along with saquon
and an offensive line that appears to be
built and ready
for this moment that is an under
reported
conversation i think right now um
and you do think though that the formula
is there for big blue
i absolutely do um first of all they got
some skill players now like evan ingram
kyle rudolph
obviously you mentioned the addition of
kenny golidy shep is a really good slot
and then kaderius tony so i called a
couple florida games
for espn because doing college football
on the weekends and
doing florida games two guys just
massively stood out for their offense
juan cow pits who we've talked about and
two was kedarius tony
and yes he did remind you a little bit
of percy harvin
probably a little bit more of tyler
lockett for me where it's like you just
i mean think about this if you're jason
garrett and you're the giants and you're
getting
saquon barkley back healthy right this
is the assuming he's healthy
i mean if i get 70 offensive snaps a
game
kedarius tony and saquon barkley are
getting 30 plus of them
like that's you feel really good about
that because those guys
the nfl game right now is about touches
and space
it's not about the old school balance of
run versus past it's touches
and space and if i can get those two
guys
touches in space 30 times a game daniel
jones job is going to be really easy and
i don't care how many times i have to do
it or how different i have to do it with
him and so
while the offensive line is still a
little question markish for me
and i know dave gettleman says that they
have higher expectations than the
national media when it comes to the
offensive line
that you still got to go prove it to me
at that side or that
aspect of the um the line of scrimmage
um
but daniel jones job is relatively easy
this year
um i'd say the two things for him for
him to prove that
or to take this team to the playoffs
which he should rich
which he should and to prove that he's
the guy for the future
one stop with the stupidity like in
those moments where
he's got to get rid of 12 plays a season
the stupid 12 plays were like dude
why are you panicking with the football
in that moment stop that is stupid
you're too smart to be
stupid with the ball in that moment okay
and
two is there's going to be again 10 or
12 plays this season where the play
doesn't work
okay defense wins the rep show me you
can be a guy who goes above the x's and
o's
so we're talking 24 plays right 24 to 30
plays this year
where daniel jones takes this team to
the playoffs and daniel jones
kind of silences a lot of critics last
one for you dan arlovsky
uh what do you think is going on with
aaron rodgers
and the packers i i still every single
time i
i i think i've got an answer and i've
got my uh my
you know arms wrapped around it it's
something it looks something completely
different the analogy we've we've been
using here is like that
seinfeld girlfriend that looks great in
a certain light and then a certain light
does not
it's just something that's constantly
changing what do you think is happening
with aaron rodgers
yeah i obviously think it's very much so
relational you know
that that he is feels offended
disrespected lacks trust right without
trust there is nothing
you know without communication there is
no reason for us to go
forward i was thinking about this this
morning though rich because
for for all the um probably the
uneasiness or unrest or disrespect or
emotional feelings that aaron
might be having with his organization it
is a reality to sit here and say
this is where i think the agent comes
into play big in this situation and his
agent is the guy that i had david dunn
athletes first he's one of the best most
powerful most connected agents
in the nfl because the truth is if aaron
rodgers is that
upset about what's going on in green bay
the question becomes
one does he really want to go and two
if he wants to go or no let me phrase it
like this what's more important
leaving or getting out and going to a
contender
because i can't imagine aaron rodgers
because his agent david dunn is probably
sitting there talking to these
teams and going okay who of you are
actually interested in
in making this happen right because
you'd have to go
back to aaron rodgers the player you
represent and go aaron
hey the only team that's really going to
make an offer that the packers are going
to entertain is let's say the las vegas
raiders
right okay if you're aaron rodgers do
you want to go
end the last three of your years of your
career with the raiders
who don't have a win now roster whose
defense is not very good
are you like is it worse leaving green
bay
to go to the raiders who you're unlikely
to win a super bowl with
or is it worth staying in figuring it
out because if david dunn tells him hey
man
um these teams they're not contenders
and their roster isn't
good that's when aaron's gonna have to
sit back and go whoa
you know i got a team in green bay that
we think we can go into super bowl with
i might have to figure out a way to get
this
right and stay now if he comes back and
goes the denver rockers are in
aaron ain't going back right if the
denver denver broncos are going to sell
the farm
aaron's not going back why do you like
the broncos
what do you think i think i i'll i'll
put it like this way rich
if the broncos go and trade three or
four first-round picks for aaron rodgers
the chiefs are scared the chiefs are
concerned
because the broncos got a top i don't
know six
seven defense they got a defensive
coordinator head coach that's phenomenal
they got pieces and weapons on offense
sutton's going to be back healthy really
good
vance is really good they got a a very
much so
improved offensive line they have pieces
that is a team that if aaron rodgers
goes to them
the chiefs and the afc are concerned and
they are
no question bonafide super bowl
contenders
so why wouldn't the broncos do something
like that because the packers aren't
entertaining it or what
well no i i think the broncos would and
will
you know i i think the broncos will be
very aggressive to it
what the price is going to be i i would
imagine it's three or four first
rounders
i mean maybe drew locke or they flip or
something like that but
i don't you know it and candidly like
green bay i've said this should
entertain it
you started this clock a year ago you
were expecting
for this light to happen um and so i
think the broncos will
dan appreciate the time uh dan arlovsky
of nfl live and the worldwide leader in
sports
uh college and professional football
let's do this more often dan
look for my call thank you boss right
back at you anytime brother you got it
that's dan orlovsky i follow him on
twitter you should as well
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here